déterminés les forces les faiblesses les
opportunités et les menaces d'une
société les critères de définition d'une
stratégie pour une entreprise
ces personnes en formation pour devenir
contrôleur de gestion suivent trois
jours de cours de stratégie ce qu'ils
doivent savoir faire c'est d'expliquer
eux les liens entre la stratégie et
l'opérationnel à travers les indicateurs
de performance les actions les
procédures les systèmes ancienne
directrice de supermarchés chaima
lemoine a décidé de faire une rupture
conventionnelle
après réflexion elle décide de suivre
une formation en fait je voulais
vraiment prendre un nouveau tournant
dans ma carrière avec mon expérience
professionnelle je voulais me
spécialiser en contrôle de gestion plage
veux vraiment me spécialiser acquérir
les compétences par exemple sur excel
sur les différents outils qui vont me
permettre de donner des prêts qu aux
entreprises comptabilité marketing
ressources humaines ou développement web
l'institut ifo coop de montigny le
bretonneux propose 20 sessions de
formation par an dans des activités du
tertiaire quatre mois de cours quatre
mois en entreprise
près de 300 stagiaires sont accueillis
chaque année nous accueillons environ 80
% de demandeurs d'emploi et 20 % de
salariés sur le centre de montigny là
nous venons d'avoir des sorties sur
justement gestionnaire de paie et rh
on est à plus de 90% ça veut dire que
les stagiaires se voit proposer un cdd
ou un cdi dans leur entreprise de stage
d'après les chiffres de pôle emploi plus
de 790 1202 d'emploi sont entrés en
formation en 2019